-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a game
called "Box of Lies."
But I'm going to need some help.
Joining me is a very talented
actress who stars in the new
movie, "Scream VI,"
which is in theaters tomorrow.
She's also hosting "Saturday
Night Live" this weekend
with musical guest, The 1975.
Please welcome Jenna Ortega!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. Now, Jenna, here's how
this works, okay?
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
describe it to your opponent.
Then they have to guess
if you're lying or telling
the truth.
Jenna, you pick the first box.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Three?
[ Drum roll ]
-You are choosing three.
Huh, it looks --
it looks light.
-[ Groans ]
-Yeah, too late.
Too late to act now.
-Now?
-Too late to act now.
I know it's light.
Are you going to lie or are you
going to tell the truth?
Very interesting. Jenna Ortega.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Tapping ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Interesting.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, I see.
You're making sounds.
You're distracting me. Yeah.
-You don't know what's
happening to you.
-What is in your box?
-Can I be honest with you,
Jimmy?
-Yes, you can always be honest
with me.
-I don't -- I'm -- I'm not sure
I even understand
what's happening here.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't understand
what's happening?
So, this thing that you are now
looking at,
you don't understand.
-I don't.
-Can you describe it?
-I fear of being a bit too
on the nose,
but it is
"Addams Family"-themed.
-Yeah. Well, we knew that you
were coming on.
-Cousin Itt.
Yeah, well, it would make sense.
-It would make sense.
We did book you.
-Cousin Itt.
He happens to be reading
a magazine of some sorts,
perhaps like "Vanity Fair"
Chewbacca edition?
[ Laughter ]
-Cousin Itt is reading
a magazine
and it could be "Vanity Fair."
-Yeah, on a nice bench.
-Bench? So, he's outside.
-Yeah, he's outside.
It seems to be a nice park,
Central Park,
if you will, in New York.
-Oh, it's New York.
So he's in Central Park?
-There may be a corgi involved.
-It's a corgi?
-Yeah.
-So, Cousin Itt owns a dog?
[ Laughter ]
Cousin Itt owns a pet?
-I guess so.
-So there's a lot of hair.
There's a lot of hair.
Is Cousin Itt wearing a hat?
-Yes, he is.
Like he always does.
He always has a hat.
-Yeah.
But if you took your time
answering that,
that would mean
that you're lying.
So I think that you are...
telling the truth!
[ Drum roll ]
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-Wow!
"Vanity Fair."
-Honestly --
-Chewbacca? It's weird.
That is odd.
-Yeah, I should have lied
because it's way too niche.
Like, the "Vanity Fair"
Chewbacca article, instantly --
-Yeah, we wouldn't do that.
Alright.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
[ Drum roll ]
-Two! Two!
-Oh, my back!
-I already did that.
-[ Groaning ]
Ooh!
-Ohh!
-Ooh! Here we go.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
It's a painting.
-Painting of what?
-Famous, famous,
famous painting.
Something you'd see in a museum.
-I feel like you have to be
more specific on this game.
-I don't think -- I don't want
to be more specific.
I want to be vague.
Think of a famous painting.
-Oh, so it's just a painting.
Don't tell me it's
the Edvard Munch, the --
-"The Scream"?
-Ooh.
-Ooh, that's interesting.
-That's a bit on the nose too.
-Well, you do have a movie
called "Scream" coming out.
So, that's pretty funny,
not niche.
[ Laughter ]
Now, now, here's what makes it
funny.
It's not -- The painting's face.
It's Colonel Sanders.
[ Laughter ]
-Colonel Sanders is very funny.
-Colonel Sanders is funny.
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
[ Laughter ]
I love this.
In fact, I want to keep it
and hang it in my bedroom
because I love it.
It's so funny. There you go.
It's "The Scream,"
Colonel Sanders scream.
-Honestly, I feel like
Colonel Sanders is pretty funny.
Just to repeat myself.
-He's not supposed to be funny.
He's selling food.
-I think it's -- I think --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I feel like you might be telling
the truuuuu...
[ Woman shouts indistinctly ]
-Did you just say something
in Spanish?
Wait, what did you just say?
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
I feel like you just helped
somehow.
-Maybe it's a lie. Maybe it's a
lie. Maybe it's a lie.
Maybe two on-the-nose
references.
I'm sorry, I'm taking forever.
It's just 'cause
I really don't know.
I don't really care.
I'm going to go with truth.
[ Laughter ]
-No! I was lying!
[ Buzzer ]
The "Mona Lisa."
-Oh, my God. You just took --
-Really a good actor.
Thank you.
-No.
-Did you say my acting skills
are fantastic?
That's so nice of you.
-Yeah, that's ex-- Yes.
-Thank you!
Thank you!
[ Laughter ]
Time to pick a number.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
One more.
[ Drum roll ]
-I'm serious.
-This is it.
This is it.
For all the marbles.
Jenna Ortega, pick a nombre.
Uno.
-Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wow, it's a bowling ball.
It's a bowling ball. Wow.
Alright, so it really is heavy.
Oh, my goodness. Alright.
-What if I broke it
or something?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Sorry.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
♪♪
-Why are you being --
Why are you being so serious?
♪♪
Roots, your music is, like,
giving me trips or something.
I'm tripping out.
I'm like, "Wah, wah."
-Uh, we have, um...
It's a bobblehead.
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
-It's a bobblehead.
-It's a bobblehead?
-A bobblehead of Peter Pan.
Um, he seems to be in a bit more
of a --
like a -- like a business
attire.
[ Laughter ]
He's got kind of
like the Leonard Cohen --
-Peter Pan in, like,
a business suit?
-Peter Pan in a business-esque
suit.
He's wearing a hat that's a bit
more of like
a Leonard Cohen fedora hat.
And he's --
[ Laughter ]
-Leonard Cohen. That's so funny.
-But it's also in a cowboy hat
with wheels
and marshmallows all in there.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you just naming words?
Are you just saying words?
-There are so many marshmallows
in there.
-You just said 20 words.
-There's so many marshmallows
in there.
-Peter Pan is on a marshmallow?
-No, there's -- So, cowboy hat.
-Uh-huh.
-Truck wheels.
-Yeah.
-Bunch of marshmallows in there.
In there is a bobblehead
figurine of
Peter Pan wearing
a business suit.
[ Laughter ]
-If you're lying,
it's pretty good.
You have a good imagination.
If you're telling the truth,
props to my props department.
[ Laughter ]
Props to props.
Welcome back to
"Props to Props."
-Yeah.
-Jenna, I feel like
we're besties.
And if we are, I would know
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
And I think you are...
[ Drum roll ]
[ Laughter ]
...telling ze truth!
-I lie.
-Oh, my God!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Bell dinging ]
Come on!
Don't eat that. Don't eat that.
Jenna Ortega, everybody!
Come right back.
More "Tonight Show."
We're talking with Jenna.
Come on back, come on back.